[Music]
Avengers infinity war had people crying
in their seats but it could have also
had audiences barfing in their popcorn
in a recent conversation with IGN
co-screenwriter Christopher Markus
described the scene which was scripted
but never shot for the movie it's a good
thing too because it might have taken
the audience right out of the film story
by making them sick to their stomachs
Markus described the scene which would
have happened early on an infinity war
he said it was a scene of basically
Widow and Falcon and cap and hiding
post-civil war and they'd just been
through a big fight with criminals and
cap was eating mashed potatoes and
Falcon says you're bleeding into your
mashed potatoes cap looks at Falcon like
yeah he is bleeding into his mashed
potatoes I remember Kevin Feige going
he's bleeding into his mashed potatoes I
don't want to see that yeah maybe we
went a little too something I think it's
gratuitous but whatever
it's far mr. Marcus the word you're
looking for is far stoic soldier that he
is we suppose it's pretty easy to
imagine Captain America being wholly
unconcerned by the fact that he's
chowing down on bloody potatoes but as
usual it appears that figis instincts
were pretty spot-on here because we're
sure that nobody wanted to see that of
course when you're scripting an
absolutely massive crossover film like
infinity war you're gonna have a few
things that don't make the final cut
during their appearance at San Diego
comic-con this past summer Marcus and
his co-writer Stephen McFeely talked
about a couple of other notable scenes
that didn't make it past the conception
stage one that would have been really
cool and another that well would have
quotes suck rocks as McFeely delicately
put it this would have been the original
version of poor's adventure which in the
finished film had him journeying to knit
of a Lear to convince the giant dwarf a
tree to craft him a battle axe capable
of taking down Thanos it proved to be a
tense funny memorable sequence Thor was
forced to essentially kickstart a dying
star
Ian Rocket began to forge a sweet bond
and Groot assisted with mounting
Stormbreaker the weapon with which Thor
would ultimately fail to go for the head
have gone for that yeah yeah we know
Thanos God give it a rest already anyway
it's not so much that Markus and McFeely
conception of the sequence was different
it's more that the pair simply had no
idea what to do with Thor during the
film Markus explained that what they
came up with was quote much to adventure
related and insufficiently character
based and involved Thor battling a giant
snake mcfeely admitted that while
infinity war script was in this draft
the duo actually feared for their jobs
he confessed it was dark for a long time
because we hadn't done well enough
eventually the duo came up in the quest
and nits of a Lear which both made
narrative sense and provided some
excellent character beats for the count
of thunder while it certainly sounds
like their original plans for Thor would
have dragged the film down in the middle
another scene that didn't make it before
the cameras what involving the sorcerer
supreme Doctor Strange might have been
really cool but would have also felt
ported over from a different movie
entirely the scene would have taken
place during the confrontation on Titan
between Thanos strange Iron Man
spider-man and the guardians of the
galaxy during the fight
strange would have employed the same
trick once used on him by the ancient
one giving the mad Titan a poke in the
head that would have sent him hurtling
through the multiverse
Thanos would have been forced to relive
all of his genocidal crimes and in the
climactic moment we would have gotten
our on-screen introduction to an iconic
and immensely powerful Marvel character
The Living Tribunal a god-like being who
ensures that balance is maintained
throughout the multiverse the tribunal
would have judged evil grimace harshly
but then Thanos realizing that the whole
ordeal was just more smoke and mirrors
from strange would have basically
snapped out of it and returned to the
fight against our heroes well while that
sounds cool on paper Markus explained
that the sequence still would have
thrown off the movies Pacey equipped we
were in the middle of a really
fast-paced fight so to stop it for an
LSD trip kind of sucked the air out of
it it's always interesting to know what
might have been although it's safe to
say that Infinity Ward did not suffer
for its lack of giant serpents and
bloody mashed potatoes it just goes to
show that even the creative mind behind
our favorite movies can stumble pretty
hard and it also makes us thankful that
Feige was around to remind the a scribes
that they were not in fact writing a
horror movie check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about the Marvel Cinematic
Universe are coming soon subscribe to
our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]